ah
y
[Música]
no
en nuestra cultura de ahorita en este en
esta época ya es insostenible es
insoportable es inmoral es ilegal que
todavía se siga permitiendo
la gallística la tauromaquia las
carreras de caballos o sea ya no puede
ser tolerable ya esto ya tiene que
acabar la violencia ejercida a cualquier
ser humano oa cualquier ser vivo tiene
que parar
[Aplausos]
pues hasta cierto punto
respecto a la forma de pensar de la
gente que no quiere este tipo de eventos
pero a la gente que lo salvación a que
esto no hacemos un poquito más y que lo
traemos pues de generación en generación
es un fósil y no van a entender también
lo que uno siente lo que uno le gusta
[Música]
i
[Aplausos]